llegó el momento para hablar de la
economía con nuestra compañera Daniela
Blandón Daniela bienvenida directo
América qué tal Rodrigo Buenas noches
muy bien ya preparados aquí para hablar
hoy de los ministros de finanzas del g7
una reunión que ha comenzado en Japón
Así es en la Ciudad de nigata están los
representantes de Estados Unidos Japón
Alemania Gran Bretaña Francia Italia y
Canadá además de la Unión Europea todos
ellos conforman este grupo de los siete
la ceremonia de inicio tuvo como
protagonistas a Janeth jelen la
secretaria del tesoro de Estados Unidos
y varios de sus homólogos abriendo
barriles de saque japonés con mazos de
madera y aunque se esperaba que después
se discutiera toda una variedad de temas
económicos como la situación en Ucrania
o la de los bancos yelen también eclipsó
la agenda hablando de la falta de
acuerdo sobre el aumento del techo de
dota
aparte de un incumplimiento de la
política arriesgada sobre el límite de
la deuda también pueden poner costos
económicos serios
sabemos esto por la historia reciente
como aprendimos en 2011 solo La amenaza
grave de incumplimiento puede Conducir a
una rebaja en nuestra calificación
crediticia y un debilitamiento de
confianza del consumidor podríamos ver
un aumento en las tasas de interés que
incremente los pagos de hipotecas
préstamos para automóviles y tarjetas de
crédito
Bueno si ya usaban las masas para abrir
el saque no quiero saber que han hecho
con ellas después de beberse todos esos
litros de saque Daniela vamos ahora
hasta Ecuador porque Busca reducir
impuestos a la renta familiar por lo
menos eso es lo que dice el gobierno que
presentó un proyecto de ley con mensaje
de urgencia dirigido a más de 300.000
contribuyentes que pagan este impuesto a
la renta lo que se busca es aumentar los
gastos deducibles anuales hasta un poco
más de 15 mil dólares esto es tres veces
más que lo actual dependiendo del número
de familiares a cargo lo que uno puede
deducir Rodrigo son los gastos que al
final no se van a ver reflejados en ese
impuesto de renta se prevé que cada uno
de estos ciudadanos tenga un ahorro
promedio de 558 dólares en su pago de
impuesto a la renta según el ejecutivo
son
195 millones de dólares que se van a
quedar en los hogares Ecuatorianos para
financiar los gastos de Salud Educación
o alimentación y recreación también de
la familia ecuatoriana esta reforma debe
ser tramitada por la asamblea nacional
en un plazo máximo de 30 días como manda
la ley
Daniela estábamos escuchando a Guillermo
lasso vamos ahora a hablar de Manuel
macron el presidente francés que ha
presentado hoy un plan de
reindustrialización del país Bueno pues
usted recordará que en los momentos más
álgidos de la polémica por la aprobación
de la Reforma pensional Emanuel macron
dijo que el país lo que necesitaba era
modernizar la industria y mejorar el
empleo hoy reveló que entre sus planes
está entregar créditos Fiscales y
también otras medidas para favorecer a
la industria sobre todo la ecológica y
la nacional y pidió además Una pausa
regulatoria europea en términos de
restricciones ambientales diciendo que
ya se había hecho mucho y que ahora se
necesita esa estabilidad en las reglas
del juego para que puedan llegar las
inversiones
básicamente vamos a apoyar las baterías
y los vehículos que se producen en
Europa porque su huella de carbono es
buena pero sin que ellos signifique que
estemos siendo proteccionistas o vayamos
a cerrar el mercado no vamos a utilizar
el dinero de los contribuyentes
franceses para acelerar la
industrialización no europea
industrialización no europea lo
mencionan hombres específicos pero
claramente se refiere a Estados Unidos
pues ha expresado reiteradamente su
alarma por lo que considera políticas
proteccionistas de la administración de
Joe biden con esta ley de reducción de
inflación Para apoyar la industria y la
transición energética y también ha
estado Europa de defenderse de esta
competencia así como del poder emergente
de China bueno Y es que macron
últimamente ha sido bastante crítico con
la Unión Europea y esa dependencia que
él dice que a veces tiene la Unión con
respecto a Estados Unidos Daniela
veremos Cómo ese tema vamos ahora con
las bolsas que nos indican hoy es la
bolsa de Nueva York que cerró mixta con
su principal índice el dow Jones de
industriales acumulando cuatro días en
rojo solamente hoy la que arrastró este
índice fue Disney que perdió más del 8%
en bolsa Eso quiere decir unos 16 mil
millones de dólares después de revelar
El Éxodo de más de 4 millones de
usuarios de la plataforma Disney Plaza
Por otra parte el dueño de Twitter elon
musk reveló que designará a una mujer
como nueva ceo de la empresa quien
tomara posesión en unas seis semanas no
reveló su nombre pero el diario
estadounidense de Wall Street journal
dijo que la ex jefe de publicidad de mbc
Universal linda yacalino está en
conversaciones agregó que ahora será el
director de tecnología pues estaremos
atentos a lo que siga ocurriendo con
Twitter que cada poco nos va dando
noticias Daniela Muchas gracias por este
repaso económico nos vemos mañana nos
vemos mañana te invito a que sigas con
nosotros en directo